Mackenzie Robert kahindi Katana the mood
is sombering court but not for everyone
even a man accused of mass murder
Paul and Tenga McKenzie the
self-proclaimed pastor and his
co-accused face several charges
including terrorism-related offenses the
investig
ators that we pointed out to this court
earlier on my lady we are looking at
charges underwater we are looking at
charges under the proceeds of crime and
money laundering act we are looking at
very
complex investigations my lady
the case has been transferred to the
high court in Mombasa where
terrorism-related cases can be tried
Mackenzie is accused of urging his
followers to starve themselves to death
so that they can go to heaven
police have found the remains of more
than a hundred people including children
on his land
it seems like following Jesus Christ is
the biggest crime in the world
away from the bustle of the courtroom a
mother clings to hope her daughter
husband and three children may still be
alive
I know the survivors because I was part
of the congregation I have asked if they
have seen my family but they are not
talking
Pathologists are carrying out autopsies
to determine the cause of death as the
search for more bodies continues
many Kenyans are still in shock they are
asking how something like this could
have gone on for so long undetected
is well known by police and has been
arrested several times before but each
time he was released because of a lack
of evidence some rights groups say they
had received reports of extreme fasting
in southeastern chakahola region as
early as February they accused the
police of not responding fast enough we
thought it was a place where these
congregants are with the fact that we
were so that they were starving or they
were fasting then it was in a harmful
place the number of people being rescued
is dwindling while the bodies keep
piling up Michael Apple Al Jazeera